[Music]
you thought he was cheating and he
called you crazy yep because yeah I've
done that you've done that
women are insane this is why women are
crazy I'm literally older than you and
you're calling me a baby
I have the exact same expectation and
standard it's just seen as normal
[Music]
hey hi nice to meet you nice to meet you
what's your name Alicia Alicia
I'm snico it's like a real name yes
that's it no oh should I tell you yeah
what's your real name Hubert Hubert you
can call me Hubie though
sneakers better than Hubert yeah where
you coming from you're coming to the gym
um no I literally woke up
so just through the song what time is it
six so you must have been partying out
late last night yeah I don't even know
it pretty much you party every night
yeah
yeah like four times a week you work at
the club or just for fun just for fun
what do you
how do you stay up that late you do
some party favors
um
no I just
do every night because I like it
London clubs like they always close
really early for my experience it was
hard to find anything that was open yeah
they did kind of but like
I mean there's something around a bit
later but I don't know why'd you get
some bars to her says bars yeah
what do you why do you like to party so
much
I'm depressed probably
what makes you depressed you're so
smiley I don't know well I just do it
together I don't know
just to get my mind off things and just
relax
just relax yeah it's a pretty
intense environment loud music alcohol a
bunch of people like touching you
um true but
do you like I was a good club in or not
really yeah I like a lot of different
types of girls really yeah
fair enough do you like guys that go
clubbing no
I don't think I'd like properly date a
guy was coming
this is too much
so what do you expect to meet this guy
um Street sort of thing on the street
yeah have you been approached on the
street people do that in London
sometimes what do they say
painting
what are you saying
you would respond well if I said what
are you saying fam yeah
I'll be like serious about me
[Laughter]
okay
um
what's your body count oh my gosh that's
such an extreme question that's such a
private question
um
to be honest
it's not like it's really high but I
don't actually know
you lost count no because I don't like
count because I didn't I don't know what
I count to be honest what do you mean I
don't know what like
like what I would count as
I don't know penetration yeah that's
what it counts I don't know if I can't
I'm trying why not because the liar just
didn't really work
Ed they definitely counts though
it just I mean even the bad ones they
still they're still part of that
experience
okay probably like
20 of them okay
what about you
I lost count I'm just like actually I
really like girls who go clubbing oh
really yeah
party girls party girls
so what do you do when when you party do
you have it you go out with friends you
just meet people there
um
have a good time
drinking the Vodka right now actually
right now yeah you woke up an hour ago I
know
but
well so it's break it down last night
what was your night like last night
it was like a gay club like we didn't
know it was a gay club so it was a bit
interesting there's some weird acts
there
really like
and stuff
you're getting a lot of notifications
not really it's been buzzing
is that hers it's not my boyfriend it's
just like I don't know
yeah it's not guys I don't text guys
okay so you're at a at a gay club
it's like a drag drag party thing and it
was like basically like really weird
acts like he had a fairies with like bun
plugs and stuff oh so yeah we're just
watching it and we were like okay
I don't know if you guys that type of
Club again but it was interesting about
plugs and fairies yeah how long were you
there you didn't just leave immediately
no we just stay because we were drunk so
when you're drunk but anyways a good
environment to be far
that's not true I think it's true if I'm
drunk enough anyway it's good you know a
place sucks when you're drunk Well
church
why'd you attract to a drug off that's
what I'm saying there's a lot of
environments that suck when you're drunk
I mean like clubs like any club is good
enough if you're drunk enough
okay what do you think that you're I'm
like interview I'm going in you can ask
me something go ahead I'm just trying to
but what do you think you're distracting
yourself from by by clubbing this often
ah probably a uni work
the boredom
so something I just procrastinate and
like don't really
I don't know it was just like a
easy activity to do it's just
there like when people invite you just
like yeah okay
you're not bored of it yet
I'm a bit more bored of it than I was
like I used to get more excited about it
but I still like it but how old are you
19. you're only 19. yeah
wow
look older you don't look older but uh
it's just that's a lot that's a lot of
Hardcore partying and that you're doing
it at 19 years old I feel like I don't
want to like look back at what being 18
19 and be like I didn't do anything
driving I didn't go have you ever met an
80 90 year old who said I wish I went
clubbing a drag queen Baltimore I wish I
saw more butt plugs you ever heard a
grandma say that
low but neither have I don't know I feel
like I'll regret like if I'm like 23 24
and I'm like okay I'm gonna calm down
the clubs like
if I didn't go at 18 19 I thought I'd go
yeah but you're not really seeing
anything new after
like five times at the club you kind of
know what the club is like
yes once in a while you'll step into a
fairy bar but is that really
there's a lot more in the world to see
there's a lot more experiences lots more
feelings and especially you're saying
it's repetitive I do lots of trouble as
well to Dubai let's go to the clubs oh
no
throw that oh nothing so
like a loop in Spain magalu yeah it was
like nice era in Spain okay
that people are flying you out there
um yeah no I only like once I don't say
that to the Buy
where'd you meet this guy
Instagram Club Mayfair Club Rich guys so
come to Dubai flew out yeah
did you like it yeah it was fun last
holiday
did you go with your friends or did you
go alone just just with him
just soda holiday basically
do you have anything to ask me
um do you live in London I don't do I
sound like I do well I no actually just
visiting yeah
um do you want kids
yeah
it's later on in life how old maybe like
late 20s or
yeah late 20s late 20s okay let's say 28
yeah and you want to You're Gonna Keep
partying 100 no after 20 after 25 I'll
probably stop going clubbing so six more
years of hard partying yeah okay
um what type of guy do you want to
settle down with
um just a guy that will just
I don't know
just let me just sit at home and do
nothing
so we get to work
so it's like a bit housewife you're
going to be a housewife after all this
okay yeah so he has to be rich not rich
but just like he's got to be successful
successful right how tall is he
oh they're actually mines like I'm quite
short so we'll be like 5 10 at least at
least five ten
and does he have any other wives does he
have any other girlfriends are you the
only one other wives yeah no I don't
want otherwise so you're the main yeah
okay
do you think that this guy that you're
imagining right now he's 510 plus he's
probably making over six figures
and you're gonna he's gonna be
monogamous to you
do you think that you are going to be
able to find that guy easier right now
when you're 19 you have around 20 bodies
or after when you're 28 and You're Gonna
Keep hard partying for six more years
you think it's gonna be easier to find
them now or after six more years of
partying
six four years don't you think that this
guy he's got to be monogamous to you
rich over five ten
do you think that he's going to settle
with the girl who's been partying hard
in Dubai and Spain and going to the club
every night for years
oh 100 he's gonna know I'll just say I
used to spend my time in uni because I'm
in uni so I'll just say I was just a
student just being normal going out
sometimes once in a while so you're
gonna lie to the father of your children
no I'm just gonna say to say like I'll
just live the normal unit experience
which is going out generally you know
okay
so
so you're gonna you're gonna lie to him
no I'm just gonna say I did normal
things I went out
okay
what if he asks you like how much
partying you're doing like you're gonna
have the same conversation that we're
having right now 100 with the father of
the children that's conversation is
going to happen pretty soon
and especially a guy who's accomplished
successful and also monogamous so he
makes sense he's going to be able to see
this even if you don't have this
conversation as strict as we're having
it right now it's going to be able to
figure it out pretty quickly
how Instagram this is going on the
internet
I mean wait what why babies
after my own older man so he's not into
the internet and stuff then
so you would rather instead of I'm sure
like 60 50 year olds they watch this
stuff
and stuff or Tick Tock or anything like
that so you would rather keep partying
and then settle with some old guy rather
than start party now and be with
somebody that you're gonna actually be
in love with
yeah partying means that much to you
but you said yourself that it's it's the
same thing last night you were at this
butt plug party is it really worth it
I don't know
maybe not actually
maybe not you're 19. you know it's you
can you can hang up the boots
last year I didn't even go clubbing at
all like it was like you weren't even
old enough maybe like when I was first
in 80 I wasn't interested in it like it
was only since like end of last year
when I turned 19 really that I've been
like
doing it alone so
I can live without it but I just
don't want to right now
I drink up
cheers
do not drink no that's wrong well not at
all never
thank you that's the oh that's the red
light
oh
well that's it unless uh you want to
come back for another round we can get
you oh is this gonna be on her YouTube
channel yeah
cool okay all right well nice to meet
you nice to meet you too
maybe I'll see you at the club yeah you
might see me at the club
Solus Haram she has that stare that
[Music]
you guys know what stare that is I don't
want to go say it because it's
disrespectful but that was
it's sad to see because she's she's um
she's beautiful but
[Music]
yeah that's uh and she said herself
she's depressed and she's gonna keep on
doing what's making her depressed she
woke up an hour ago she's drinking she's
going back to the club tonight she just
came from a club and she's only 19 and
she wants to do six more years of
partying and she's getting bored of it
how have you already planned in your
head that that's the next six years of
your life she's gonna spend all her
youth getting [__] by guys in the club
getting flannel to Dubai in Spain by
random people that she meets and then
settle down when she's 28 it's just like
the mentality a lot of these girls it's
and they say that all the time that it's
just like oh these just Miami girls are
just like that we're in London it's and
I knew exactly the blueprint it's uh
it's a feminism problem it's a it's a
wokeness problem it's too bad though I
would I would
pull it out though
I would I mean I would I would I know I
know I know after Ramadan
yeah I'm ashamed of myself too but I
might even get a number to be honest I
mean she's guaranteed like if we're
gonna go like I'm not gonna be in London
that long you're going to talk about
guarantee like
see this is the best bet if you want to
go like now
[Music]
let's be honest but Haram
you want to tame a drug dealer yeah
so you leave yeah
I thought you wanted to have kids what
are you talking about I like nice girls
I like girls that
[Music]
I like you oh yeah